are you live
we did it we're live again we're back to
being live
we have returned we did it
yeah apologies for that guys we don't
know what the [ __ ] happened
it's an excellent connection right now i
think just the program
got a little overwhelmed probably it was
like you're doing things that we're not
you're not used to you doing
you're live broadcasting and creating
all new elements guys for sticking with
us
yeah thank you so much guys thank you to
everyone who's jumped back into this
stream
i got to my goodness all right
so let me check here i want to see how
behind we are we're pretty behind we're
pretty behind we're very we got to make
sure we're moving at a steady pace from
here on out
well we got this uh halo trailer right
here we're gonna jump back in with that
we're gonna just hop right back into the
stream thank you to everyone inform the
people in the previous live stream chat
if they're there that we're back on this
one
all righty all right let's do it
for sylvester uh sergio we
[Music]
thought
die
i mean you can
[Music]
dude you know people give the campaign
to
the eight minute one of crap but i i
still think it looks pretty [ __ ]
awesome
i mean it looks like a halo game to me
you know
although maybe that's it maybe people
want something a little bit more out of
the box
yeah i don't know to me it looks like a
halo game
oh that looks great yeah
not bad that looks pretty awesome all
right so do we have the stream working
properly right now
that sucks we were at like 200 viewers
and the stream just crashed
no but now we're at 69 dude 69 man it's
perfect all righty well who's next who's
next in here
all right we got um who do we got here
this wolf pack gaming
wolf pack gaming nice to see you back in
our stream buddy he's saying ubisoft and
massive entertainment is working on a
movie for division starring jake
gyllenhaal
and jessica chastain and directed by
david leach
what what's coming on netflix what do
you think
um i feel like that would be a perfect
combo
j i mean we haven't seen jake gyllenhaal
really embody an action role in such a
long time
i mean mysterio doesn't really count
it's more part of the
intellectual side and then jessica
chastain i know can pull that [ __ ] off
so i and then i have david leach
directing it i fee i
i kind of wish chad stahlski was the one
doing it
because i feel like he's actually the
better half of the john wick duo
that being said um yeah i think
i feel like that would be a perfect
combination i'm excited for it
hopefully it actually gets off the
ground and it could probably be the best
video game movie
ever done if they pull this off
[Music]
goodness gracious me they're gonna well
maybe that's the way though maybe if
these video game companies start being
the ones to produce the movies maybe
they will
get the spirits right yeah you know or
something like that
all right so uh but thank you wolf pack
gaming for the question
yeah anissa's back and the rental
directorial debut of dave franco
all right john let's do this calmly i
haven't played
goes to sema yet um i we have it in our
home mm-hmm
haven't been it maybe maybe it was the
song that affected it
i don't know i mean it could be so
visible
but i don't think that it would cause
the entire program just to crash i mean
that's fair yeah
it's just because it didn't crash
youtube it just crashed streamlabs all
right so right now
we're gonna be watching the rental
trailer
of and i heard that this movie was like
[ __ ]
scary people be liking it yeah i've
heard a lot about it i haven't seen
anything about it um other than i heard
dave franco directed a movie that is
supposedly pretty [ __ ] scary
yeah but this sounds like this could be
right up our alley i love sony steve
mann in the chat said halo fans before
too realistic i hate it halo fans now
graphics suck i hate it which that was
the one thing uh he's
jesus the gaming community in general
complains too much that was the one
thing about that trailer was like do
people not like the graphics maybe is
that it
like because it does look like an older
halo game yeah i don't really care i
just
care that i could go live on halo and
keep losing
look at that yeah that's the way i roll
when it comes to halo whew
get a little bit of uh we'll cut the
bottom bar off
all right the rental we're watching the
trailer for the rental right now let me
show you out back and then i'll
get out of your hair the stars are
insane out here i should have brought
the telescope
oh we need to tell us getting the city
for unless you're like a beeping tom or
something
you're me
tell me that's not a camera whoa i know
someone who that
what happened to you what yeah i won't
say who else she's been a guest on this
channel but
it was true what's going on crazy [ __ ]
oh god
oh damn oh damn
look this is not okay charlie all right
stop being so god everything is fine
dude dave franco my man
[Music]
not bad at all
oh man that is like my kind of horror
movie right there yeah
lo-fi one-location independent or
grounded and like as realistic as
possible that looks very unsettling very
uncomfortable
it's out now right isn't it out we can
rent it yeah
and it also looks like a good version of
one of those like
what if you did a horror movie about
airbnb
that's out to kill you yeah or like a
lyft driver without to kill you
or something like that so uh yeah
and i mean uh this is how he gets out of
his big brother's positive shadow
yeah he's all the help we can get i
guess
oh man oh that's cool i want to watch
that it's i'm telling you the way you
branch out
you direct a horror movie that's the way
to do it
yeah man dave franco's the new rob
zombie great and uh and
allison brie is is sherry moon um it's
weird
i saw a thumbnail for double toasted on
this and it seemed like they were very
positive
i'm looking at a thumbnail right now of
chris stuckman's
he does not look very positive on this
he looks like he hates it
but you know chris has a very laid-back
chill demeanor
on camera i'm gonna show you guys this
all right you
know chris tucker makes it pretty
apparent when he likes something this is
double toasted
creepiest film of the year is theirs and
this is chris stuckman's face you guys
see that
it just looks like uh wow
why why do horror movies i don't know
man
that looked great and actually i feel
like i'd be
kind of inclined to trust um
what you may call it double toasted on
this one but thank but thank you
all right who's next on here newt glader
i know it's not much
i'm a college student but you all are
awesome i hope it helps it does thank
you dude shouts out to canada thank you
scamander appreciate it buddy hang in
there college is a
is a is a journey all right carter
lovejoy out of
to be fair and because of time there's
no way in hell we could do
all this right now on the stream okay to
give you an idea this if if we subtract
10 minutes from losing the previous
stream
we are about an hour and a half behind
right now
there's no way so you're gonna have to
choose
on trailers revisited uh tell us in the
stream which one do you want us to do
you gotta give us just one we gotta be
fair to uh
to everyone right now sergio was the
exception because he had two
uh super chats so yeah yeah i mean you
got we gotta be fair to everyone so just
tell us which one would you want
also real quick uh uh to those of you
who are joining this new chat who maybe
weren't on the other stream we already
did the avengers war table on the
previous live stream
so if you want to see our thoughts on
some of that footage at least a little
bit of that footage go to the previous
live stream it's got the same title just
without the word again
yeah on it all right okay carter's
saying let's okay let's get the last of
us one trailer we'll do a trailers
revisited for it
in the meantime i'm gonna update
something via
my cell phone oh look at that uh
we want the story trailer or just the
trailer trailer i would say
uh let's do the story let's do the uh
[ __ ] uh let's do the story trailer
yeah we'll do last of a story trailer
happy birthday to jaby kawai who's
tuning in here
happy mr phone call happy birthday go
away happy co-way
to you happy jabby
we wish you a happy birthday in this
livestream already you got what you
needed
you got what you got what you did all
right
we wish you a happy birthday at the very
least getting a part one of this live
stream happy birthday
all right so trailers revisited we'll do
one for the last of us part one
oh wow i haven't seen i don't think i've
ever seen a last of us
trailer actually i like the first for
the first game
well strap it for this
small trailer
oh my god please let me make the size
right there we go
do i need to remind you what is out
there
upon a time
i had somebody that i cared about and in
this world that sort of shit's good for
one thing
killing that gets killed
i need something smuggled out of the
city just cargo joel
i just want some simple gear enough to
set me on my way
i reckon it's got something to do with
that girl he's got everything to do with
that little girl
[Music]
it can't be anything oh man what a game
yeah goddamn what a great game this was
it we're shitty people joel has been
that way for a long time no we are
survivors this is our chance it is over
tess oh
what are you so afraid of you're
treading on some mighty thin eyes here
you make every shot count i forgot that
like joel's voice actually sounds a
little bit different now i mean
he's older in the second one that
actually re hearing his voice again back
actually sounds different we don't have
to do this
you know a little more gravelly
the time when this game came out and
everyone just loved the hell out of it
yeah imagine man remember that time
looking back at it something's just so
simple and then becomes this crazy
crazy mess down the road it's just
[ __ ] so good
can't please all the people all the time
and all those people
were checking out the last of us too i i
remember that oh god
as i i played the last of us one pretty
late uh like
several years after it came out and
going back and looking at it totally the
game hasn't lost its tone at all but
still you know
all right yeah man it was me in there
last of us three in the works that was
that last of us one was
like that was such you have you beat it
yet
no you've had it for years john i've had
it for a
year one year exactly
come on man we're making excuses i'm
closer than ever before
i just gotta hook up my ps3 now and i
have you not hooked up a ps3 we gave you
a television
because i'm trying to i i almost have
all the equipment i need so that i can
stream it when i start playing it
you're gonna finally stream and you're
gonna start off with the last of us one
from like many years ago there's so many
other games that you could do that right
then i'll stream for tonight i'll just
just do fortnite in minecraft you'll be
a lot happier then all right
are you starting your own gaming channel
no i just wanted to know if i could do
it because it always seemed like
something that would be fun and if it
becomes something that could be an asset
to the channel at some point hey why not
like
i almost feel like i would be more apt
to play a video game if i knew that it
was
contributing to this then just for my
own sake because if i just want to do it
for my own sake
i'm just going to get overrun by like
all the things i need to do in
waking real life that are way more
important
so like yeah if i had to do it on on on
like a stream it would probably be more
pertinent
sergio we reacted to the first one we
reacted to the campaign trailer right
when this second stream actually started
there you go so you might want to just
go back to it
yeah just bring us over here
all right john you got it that's how
that one works uh let's go down let's
see where do we leave
off we did me me maybe did it mimi
uh i think it was uh eric horseman was
the last one we did best parts
yeah yeah okay there's eric
feeling great all right so we are up to
hitman hudson
thank you can you read that because i
can't yeah thank you for the follow
on twitter john the mass effect 2
trailer is the best trailer
ever made are you asking us to cover it
to look at the mass effect
2 trailer or are you just stating yes
because we'd be happy to right now mass
effect
i play it's a mass effect i've played a
little mass effect i've had some blue
alien love making in my life
uh mass effect two of the cinematic
trailer okay
let's open that bad boy all right we're
gonna watch the mass effect 2 cinematic
trailer
this is going to be great this is i mean
mass effect is one of the most like
beloved
like it's at least a couple of those
games are like some of the most loved of
all time it seems like
here we go who's ready i'm ready yeah
peggy 18. i've never played mass effect
it's fun ah
bioware
he has no idea what he's getting into is
that michael sheen right
he's recruiting not michael sheen
[ __ ] martin sheen maybe
assassins scientists biotics he's
scouring the galaxy for the best
i think it is ilium no
it's close
[Music]
do you know what's going on or play this
game a little bit i used to play with my
friends in high school
the first one came out purgatory
even sunny to chunk up
oh there's so many people catch up on
[ __ ] i have this shit's in my list now
oh my god
look at this
[Music]
tough but are they loyal if shepard
can't gain their trust
they're all as good as dead
damn
this feels like a deal a little bit
you spent way more time in space
hmm
[ __ ] that's crazy
oh damn this is making me jump that was
[ __ ] cool
whoa i have yeah no idea what was going
on but that was
awesome
[Music]
holy [ __ ] that looked awesome
what are you looking at juani i am
putting a user in timeout because uh
you know bill cosby isn't welcoming
we ain't got no time for cosby in this
chat all right john let's see your
streaming gaming skills
let's talk talk to me about the mass
effect
tell me about mass effect oh goodness
it's like a you know
science fiction rpg of sorts and it has
a lot of uh
basically what what i remember getting
into the most because this was one of
the games we would play a lot in high
school was like you could um
it's very like all the choices that you
make as a character affect the outcome
of the game
okay so there are multiple ways to play
through it and there are these various
alien races and stuff and it's
partly you know you get to do all the
cool action and shooting and stuff but
you also have to build relationships and
you have to
you know be conscientious in the way you
choose your way through the game
so you know it's i i always preferred it
to halo because it just felt like there
was way more of a human element infused
and engaged with it but uh but yeah i
don't know
it's uh it's a pretty rad game and you
should play it all right
you should check it out can't wait for
your streaming channel
that takes off your game for 10 years
ago
i mean it's back in the zeitgeist and
people seem to really respect that first
game so i don't know i i don't
have good ideas no you do
john you definitely do but no that was
well worth it
i've never seen anything of mass effect
in my life and i was like wow this looks
really awesome it's funny i've played a
couple
of mass effect games but i've never
actually watched any of the trailers
so it's cool to see the cinematic uh
version of that yeah
all right well thank you thank you
hitman hudson yeah
um mimi's back please react to the rami
tv show trailer here is the link rami
i'm very excited actually because i've
heard great things
and i've not seen much of anything
from the show but it's one of those
shows i keep like intending to start
yeah so should we
cut so that way we can catch up should
we cut off
this the super chats and stuff from here
on out
let's review and see
we were pretty behind just how many it's
been we've been here for two hours and
we're like
we're like well over an hour behind
we're about two hours behind right now
let's see since we get back up to newt
newt
[Laughter]
the news happens every stream this is
the worst thing before
carter okay we just did carter oh okay
we did that
uh we so we we're on uh yeah we're about
an hour and 52 minutes behind
all right yeah so
no more super chats no more requests
this is exactly what i was worried about
before we went live i was like should we
even be doing this because i feel like
we're gonna fall so bad
we have requests up to the gills so uh
feel free to like comment or weigh in
with questions but in terms of
of requests we we are we are capped out
for sure
we have a lot of requests all right
we might even have to like do another
part yeah we'll have to do another video
to keep up with this
right now all right all right you want
to get this romney going
yeah let's watch the romney one said he
is
back in action
[Music]
it's been a weird year i really want to
do it the right way man i'm not going to
look at porn
nothing i just want to commit no porn
disguise there's no point
no way impossible i did it i haven't
poured in so long do you want to stay
alone forever
you don't even have a real job you do
nothing at a startup that does nothing
they are starting up
i just want to figure out my calling
brother rami
to what brings you here i want to change
and
i heard you can help me
oh [ __ ] martha it's a personality
i look at my parents and how strong they
are
maybe we should start recycling i think
we should
i want to know who i am i want to
explore they don't want a man like me
anymore
they want a man like you he's a little
bit like a woman but it's still
officially a man
look at everything has a blessing my
curse right
truth is everything is both
i'm just trying to do the right thing
whoa you just took the whole thing
what's the wrong way i'm gonna have an
experience
100 milligrams are you happy you think
it's too much oh yeah it'll [ __ ] you up
man
just buddy look out buddy he's gonna
come back
i'm definitely you know for jesus
comeback it would mean it was the end of
the world but
oh a minute i'm so
i'm so baffled by the fact that mahersha
ali is in this show
because this looks like this doesn't
look like it
it feels like a comedy that has
something on its mind
but it doesn't look like the kind of
show i'd imagine mahershal ali attaching
himself to do you know what i mean yeah
yeah yeah i mean maybe he was maybe he
was really
spoken to by the material or something
um i mean i
i don't know the 100 context but it
looks like he's also playing like a
counselor or some kind of like religious
leader so maybe
uh maybe it coincided with his real life
beliefs or something and he cared enough
to do it i don't know
wow that's really fascinating because it
just looks like a seth rogen like
a judd apatow like comedy with a bit of
more of a visual style to it
um about you know like young guy trying
to grow the [ __ ] up
and but with a more cultural aspect
exactly
and then so to see marshall they're just
like really threw me for a loop
yeah last thing i'd expect you to be a
part of
so it must be something that's a little
bit more meaningful or something like
that yeah i mean
because i i believe rami yusuf is a is a
stand up as a comedian at least is how
he's often billed to me and yeah
i mean this is one of those shows that
seems like it's definitely
gonna use some of his comedic voice but
yeah definitely
diving more into a character study of
probably what his life is like because i
have to imagine that yeah
with his background you know and and the
culture that comes with that there's
probably a lot to explore
you know well awesome yeah well thanks
so much for requesting that
much approach thanks mimi all righty uh
we go back
trail okay or do we want the yeah no
let's go through the stream laps because
we were there uh flev is next
shameless season one from warner
brothers 1.1 million viewers we're only
going to be able to take one right now
buddy
which one do you think it should be john
um i mean i don't know
anything about haven although you know
what
people keep telling me how to watch
shameless and i think they're telling
you that too
why don't we check out the first uh
shameless all right i'll watch the first
shameless trailer
from warner brothers there we go
i've never seen shameless i have no id
like
i i thought it was a comedy but i hear
it's a little bit more of that it looks
it seems like one of those dramedy's
about dysfunction where it's like there
will probably be some really funny stuff
there will probably be some really heavy
uncomfortable stuff
oh my god stop youtube oh my god
stop oh god that's probably why things
crashed as
things are getting a little loopy all
right all right here we go
uh that's not how i do that there you go
nobody's saying our neighborhood's a
garden
hey olivia but it's been a good home to
me and my kids who i'm proud of
because every single one of them reminds
me a little bit of me
[Music]
oh that doesn't look pleasant oh [ __ ]
camera monahan
you see that's the problem with working
too much instability you're almost nine
you're gonna have to start pulling your
weight
i'm still looking for fun fiona
science just turns me on what are you
hiding oh sweet jesus
oh god whoa
whoa it's just a study girl
who the hell is that my dad you must be
joking
him he's married with kids and you're
happy with that
if all you want is to be needed then got
yourself a job for life with this joker
good job fiona i don't know how i could
do this
this does look like the kind of show
john would love
the further you run the more i will kill
you
name a single time i've let you down
you're nothing
like anyone i've ever met
frank gallagher father teacher mentor
captain of our little ship
[Music]
good night daddy oh huh
not bad well john people have been
telling you forever to watch it
what did you think of the trailer i
thought it was a pretty appealing
trailer i mean you know it definitely
got me interested
and it gave me at least a little look at
the tone
so yeah william h macy's the biggest
draw
well honestly william h macy's not maybe
not the biggest draw for me what's the
biggest draw for me is the fact that
cameron monahan's in it
and justin chatwin who played goku
in the dragon ball
movie i mean the cameron monahan is in
it yeah
while i'm playing jedi fall in order i'm
just like man this guy's such an amazing
actor and i heard he was on shameless
i've never seen any
bit of shameless so the fact that he's
uh in it
that actually is more of an enticing
pull for me to finally check the show
out just to watch his career because of
every time i'm like oh man [ __ ]
cameron monahan is
the most amazing actor in the world
you're like have you seen him in
shameless the show that he was on for
all those seasons
no you don't really know cameron
monahan's work fine
you're not a real watch it you know
you're not a real fan
that's the way people treat it you know
that is the way people treat it
but uh yeah i did i did uh that that
does look like a really heart
i bet that's the kind of show that gets
insanely dark
it looks like the kind of series is like
oh look how wacky and fun this is and
then it gets like
really [ __ ] dark you know oh yeah i
mean i i gotta imagine that they're
gonna get into
all sorts of i don't know all sorts of
glasses
well yeah i mean like i have to imagine
that they're gonna be
social workers and all sort of if it's
yeah if if william h macy is the guy
that he is with all these kids and he's
just doing it on his own i can only
imagine
but yeah i mean it looks really lively
took me years to really put that joke
together which i feel
silly about from walk hard yeah
all right who's the whole game ethan
holgate hi
guys got a few short badass trailers can
only choose one today
gotta be fair well here we go all right
including the gentleman trailer from my
super chat
um everything or nothing bond game
king solomon's minds 1985. all right
which one which one
i would say the gentleman trailer
because i never actually saw the trailer
for that did you
no well i mean i i saw like
ads and spots but i never watched like
the trailer so
i i've seen bits of footage it's
somewhat of a reaction you know john you
could always ask for my help
bye anisa do you always ask for my help
to hold the microphone in case you know
i appreciate that i i will do that more
from here on out you're a good mic stand
just just ask all you gotta do is ask
her the gentleman all right all right
here we go
i've i've heard the gentleman's good but
i've never actually seen the trailer
i want you to play a game with me right
i don't want to play a game oh please
no i said play a game with me right oh
[ __ ] is that you grant
mm-hmm right lovely
[Music]
i want you to imagine a character your
boss mickey
pearson you're too smart to be
blackmailing us fletcher
sweet mary jane is my vice your poison
on the other hand
is and always has been the destroyer
golden world
you're out of touch and i would like you
to consider an offer
i am not for sale
the plot begins to thicken
now i can't be specific about the heroes
and zeros
oh [ __ ] cassandra's a hungry
there is a lot of money hanging in the
balance stream our antagonist explodes
on the scene like a millennial firework
and cruising relationship i think you
need to see this boss
how do they find it i'm making inquiries
his name is
please sorry for her kind of a hawk
and if you smell smoke it's because
there's a fire
wow this movie looks so cool
these people are gonna clean house and
you are part of that house
in the jungle the only way a lion
survives
not by acting like a gamer
by being the king
[Music]
oh it's really warming up now isn't it
[Music]
has anyone in this stream seen this
movie yet no it was the gravity that
killed him
silver gonna need those phones
yeah i haven't seen i this is my first
trailer i've seen in this movie
i've kind of like i don't know i don't
have like the
biggest faith sometimes in guy ritchie
because i i love the [ __ ] out of lock
stock and snatch
and all's everybody's been like yeah
yeah
cool i mean i guess there's always
something with guy richie where
as compared to some of his more
blockbuster stuff like whenever he goes
back to his
genre i always feel like it's worth at
least look
i mean i feel like you know sometimes
when akron directors go back to their
genre
it it can feel like they're trying to go
back to their genre and not
actually doing it yeah that looks like
he's actually
pulling it off you know what i mean yeah
exactly it does
hey i mean it kind of reminded me of
like a seven psychopaths or something
like that and
felt more akin to that than an actual
guy richie movie yeah
yeah a little bit and uh you know that's
cool i mean if he's refining his style
i'm happy to see that i would like to
check it out
man there's a lot of people in this chat
who are already saying how great it is
and we have confirmation shameless gets
dark
okay all righty patrick i'm glad we
watched that finally i've never i've
never seen it
yeah patrick we got a mystery video
didn't even tell us what the title is
i hope we're not about to get trolled
if we hit once we hit eight o'clock we
might have to reconsider how we're gonna
handle the remaining ones
that's just the same unless you guys
wanna hang out till
00 pacific standard time
uh did i actually download this no i
didn't all right we're gonna watch
next this rainbow six siege
tournament of champions rainbow six
seeds
tournament of champions breakfast of
champions
six invitational from ubisoft just
recently haven't seen it yet
ubisoft oh you be soft you'd be soft
the rainbow tournament of champions was
held in greece
the most elite operators from around the
world came together
to touch themselves and push each other
past their limits
surrounded by somebody has some
problematic things in these companies
they came to fight they came to wow
and after rounds of grueling competition
only two teams remain
culminating in a thrilling finale
absolutely no one could have predicted
[Music]
wait a minute this is like
an action tournament oh i guess so is
this going to be on the fair zone
there's a television internal use only
gustav
kateb national gender marine
intelligence
do i look at the camera mike baker
special air service
sheamus calden sanitation
i suppose the crowd surprised me the
most
i was not expecting the sheer
power of it
[Applause]
you're going hard and fast no hesitation
it means
being fully committed
attackers prepare for insertion
jesus
wow
[Music]
holy [ __ ] this
it's like the running man
i should have seen this coming i mean i
just
i should have seen it coming two
defenders remaining
wow
nice very cool mike grace
[Music]
only one defender remaining we'll get
him next time
there is no next time there was now
and we [ __ ] it up you need to relax
where is it
are they bullets it must have been
upsetting there's a paintball no one
remembers who comes
like airsoft bullets i don't know i
thought they were actually killing each
other
like actually i thought they're
murdering each other yeah that's what it
looks like
three attackers remaining going for the
bomb site
watch your six pulses
mike
this is so intense
jack you mean
rubber bullets that's what they are
i don't know why i didn't guess that
[Music]
airsoft
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah we're watching rainbow six season
tournament of champions right now
invitational 2020
[Music]
there is always next year really next
year
absolutely i will be here
damn see everything i've ever known
about rainbow six i i've always
it's always felt like one of those
tactical shooter games kind of like a
call of duty
so i'm sitting here now wondering is
this like a special
mode that they do is this like a giant
because there's not much it's
like a very it seems like a very just
different game i might
i imagine what my mind is at least
telling me is that it's online gameplay
and or it's a versus kind of game and
it's not i feel like that
i i wonder if there's like a story mode
you can actually go through on that
i mean ubisoft right now has a lot of
like real
shady [ __ ] up scandals things that are
going on in its company so
i'm going to set all that aside right
now just to be like in terms of the game
trailer itself
it looked pretty [ __ ] incredible um
like i i it looked like something that
could be an actual movie you know what i
mean
it looks like a lot of fun uh yeah i
think this is usually like an actual
tactical shooter
but no i'm saying that for this game
though like i like the competition
element
the scenes in and of itself felt very
like
like a lot of cliches all meshed into
one
but in terms of the concept and such i
look pretty it looked pretty awesome
though
hell yeah i agree it can't be a
tournament without
neonor in there as well you know gotta
have me on there
thank you patrick tongue punch deontay w
not sure if you guys can react to
commercials
but if so watch skittles yogurt boy
if you can't react to pinocchio 2020 or
kaiju kajillionaire thanks
thank you we love you um
what are you feeling here john should we
try the skittles
let's try skittles yogurt boy out of all
those i was like
we could do pinocchio 2020 or could
julia or
uh wait wait wait what what the [ __ ] is
this
okay we have to watch this okay
all right oh what the [ __ ] it don't
worry don't worry
no spoilers creepy ass thumbnail here no
spoilers we ain't spoiling this
okay where is it that yogurt boy alright
here we go who's ready
i'm ready okay there's only 16 seconds
more yogurty skittles
yoghurt
what the [ __ ] is this creamy
fantasy
well skittles commercials man
skittles specializes in that kind of
commercial where like
i remember one there's one where a dude
has acne but the acne is all skittles
and so someone's just picking them off
of his face and eating them
like they they have they have borrowed
heavily i think from like
crazy japanese commercials and stuff and
like just crazy
like international commercials to have
them be these like disturbing memes
that was a commercial we just watched
called yogurt boys that wasn't getting
to sell products that was supposed to
entice you oh my goodness
i'm gonna remember it oh no yeah i mean
i'll definitely next time i buy skittles
i'll now
i'll think of yogurt boy i'll think of
that oh buddy
what do we got here we got another
request from patrick
and it's a mystery once again patrick
loving the surprises oh thanks patrick
thanks p up this is a unavailable video
in our country we cannot watch it i'm
sorry patrick i really apologize
yeah as proof
it says right there yeah video available
not available in the country i'm sorry
pat
yeah i appreciate the support we can't
play this i'm sorry man
let me see just really quick if there's
like a re-upload or anything but
i don't know nah nothing no we uh
sorry bud i feel like i'm sorry man but
that's youtube for you they've been
blocking
things sorry but hey we just watched
your other uh the other one we thought
that was [ __ ] great
so thank you oh yeah thank you so much
uh ooh
eric can't remember if you reacted to
halloween kills
second choice is dune have you been
drunk like the entirety of the last
couple of years all right so
people heavily requested yeah that's why
let's let's do halloween kills
let's just i've only seen it briefly on
my phone forever ago
but let's let's watch the halloween
kills one yeah
and then we'll talk about it let's do a
full-on
in-depth breakdown breakdown of reaction
review
speculation we'll draft a script to the
sequel even though they're already
working on it
okay halloween kills
i i do have a comment though that i
didn't make before
i think in terms of uh
the the the [ __ ] like
the way it shot yeah i love that because
it feels like it's out of like
i don't remember if the ending felt that
i remember the last freeze frame did
at the end of halloween the one that
this is a sequel to
but i don't recall uh it being shot in a
way
that looks like it's like a 60s 70s
movie that was kind of film right i was
like oh yeah actually i forgot to look
like that and that is a big
compliment to it yeah i was about to say
that it looks like they borrowed some of
the
aesthetics from rob zombie which works
i mean it works and and yeah i mean as
far as just a little taster of a tone
piece i
i think it's a good teaser and yeah i
mean as much as it is
those fire trucks remind me of nelson
muntz uh you know ha ha uh
it's still a great i think it's still a
great moment let it burn yeah
after watching the it's like doctor who
has this thing
here's what doctor who often does uh if
you guys haven't seen it
they'll have this opening scene and it's
like and then the opening scene has this
like oh my god they're in trouble cut
roll the opening credits and then once
it cuts back from the opening credits
it's like
nope nope it's not what you thought yep
and that's kind of what this halloween
kills trailer makes me think of
oh yeah it's just like oh they got away
fire burning
and then cut to the next thing uh just
kidding there's a fire truck
it's gonna be fine there we go fire
trucks to ruin the day for everyone
don't worry they're gonna save him
they're gonna take michael to the
hospital and reverse him back to health
then he's going to break out of the
hospital like at the beginning of rob's
office halloween too
or like the entirety of halloween too
yeah
by john carpenter oh god that's funny oh
i'm glad we finally got
that out of the way we did it uh what do
we got on the the the youtubes we've got
a trailer for gangs of london
ooh a new show by gareth evans
and here's something funny uh
actually coryn hardy who we got to go
through the none uh you know monastery
maze experience with
i believe he is one of the heavies
involved with this show as well
all right let's check it out i am
excited
to see what it's all about the guy who
directed the raid right gareth evans
yes yeah yeah gareth evans all right
and uh yeah and uh oh
gotta download it though can't skip
protocols
guys thanks just again for being here
while i download this video and
stall for time but seriously though uh
john downloaded the baba yaga official
horror movie because that's not what i
wanted
you're here right that says gangs of
london right
you're you're all right
all right stop
okay this link is jacked up i'm gonna
try a new link wow that's so weird i
don't know why watching him download the
gang's london trailer and he keeps
downloading the
baba yaga horror movie trailer yeah
uh
unless it's like mis-labeled or
something
but uh yeah okay now we good we good we
good we can fix
anything don't worry don't hurt
anyone
[Music]
we're born into a certain world
okay earth is chosen for us
someone chose to kill finn wallace
today we mourn the loss of a great man
but
tomorrow it will be business as usual
[Music]
everything stops
until i find out who killed him
there's a time when nobody would have
dared touch this family
i'm going to make things right mom shaun
wallace himself
tasking me to find a guy who killed his
father
[Music]
damn i'm back here
the pub eliot you did all that on your
own
what was it six of them oh eight
but i had a dart so
[Applause]
my father was taken from us on the
streets of london
[Music]
and now london will deliver to us those
that took him
[Music]
we are making enemies out of business
partners
[Music]
we've got to find a peaceful solution to
this i'm not
interested holy [ __ ] in peace
reaction on this is a show yeah serious
holy crap
if you knew what i was doing be proud of
me
oh i see him get sean out of here now
[Music]
action cinematic show
[Music]
oh my god wow that was cool
[Music]
wow wow
those those that was nutty
that was really naughty gotta check
that shiz out jeepers it's got good
it at reviews 83 on rotten tomatoes from
the first season not too bad
i mean it looks like you're getting the
best of both worlds you're getting a
full-on gangster show
and you're getting a [ __ ] pretty
sweet action show at the same time
yeah dude martial arts and pure gore
violence
martial arts and and also just that
rough and tumble
again the things you associate with
gangs of london just this
hard harsh yeah i'm not even using the
words right this
also just just shouts out because this
uh series has a pretty
impressive just the episodes are
directed by gareth evans cory hardy and
xavier genz which he's done a lot of
like pretty
profile stuff too so uh
all right yeah well thank you hell yeah
where have we made it to selena series
netflix trailer we are at
five o'clock p.m oh god when do we start
we started like 4 40. we started at 4 40
today
oh yeah well we're all right guys we're
giving you a heads up we're killing the
game we're
probably gonna have to get to a point
where we will have to just
pick this up later will we do the we do
a video
um just in this format where we're just
going through it
all uncut and catching up on everything
and putting that up tomorrow because
yeah there's there's no way that
i i i we we did not plan accordingly for
how this would go down
yeah yeah there's just so there's a lot
of stop plan accordingly so we'll go for
a few we'll go for a little bit more
it's funny because you would think that
we we talked for a couple minutes when
we just take
questions or feedback yeah but but we
are three hours behind we are three
hours behind
we're gonna be three hours behind well
let's let's see what celine is all about
it's a it's from a niso oliva let's see
what's going on oh it's a
square selena netflix trailer
[Music]
this is a netflix series yes so based on
the
artist selena yeah
[Music]
is this about jennifer lopez auditioning
[Music]
that's it's just gonna tell about that
one day
[Music]
i
am
[Music]
ready
part one interesting part one at 20 20.
yeah it's cool she's getting a show
about her though yeah
that's what she's been waiting for right
is selena with us still no i
think she's gonna john you typed in
selena gomez i
it auto filled to selena gomez
oh goodness gracious selena chronologies
yeah it's just about her coming of age
it's just a it's a biographical series
about selena interesting
okay biographical drama web television
series
i love that like it was weird it's like
today i was just thinking about
um i was thinking about i was like you
know it'd be cool to see like a red hot
chili peppers
uh bio biography but i i wanna say
i'd wanna see it as a television show or
as like a mini series to say the least
and then it had me going like they
should do that for all biopics like a
biopic should
should be mini series
especially because they try to like
what's the most common complaint with
biopics did you try to cram too much
into one movie or oh you didn't cover
enough
i don't know you do a biopic show you
you you've got all that cover
over all and so to do that with selena
uh i think that's a really exciting
venture to set out on
yeah likewise and looks like you
actually got like
latinos to work on the show yeah well
and i mean netflix lately seems like
they're doing more to appeal
to and you know encompass the latinx
community
they just put out that uh documentary
about the entertainer whose name i am
going to forget and butcher uh
but yeah so i i think maybe they're
trying to i mean
it's funny to watch netflix because
there was a period of time where they're
like we gotta get a bunch of indian
content because that's like the new
thing so
i always wonder how like authentic these
uh pushes are
from the money people but uh yeah it's
that seems like a really cool thing to
have uh
come to light you know for them yeah for
sure yeah
um let's see here okay mm-hmm
so how about this okay we already did
the gentleman we got one knocked off
there
hey son of rambo
all right i remember when this movie was
coming out
son of rambo is the next i never saw the
trailer but i heard things about it and
it made me
interested so oh it's a youtube movie
interesting what is son of rambo
we're about to find out hold on to your
hat
which is like old as [ __ ] right it's not
cr yeah i mean it's like a reaction
catch up for the title and everyone's
a lot of people are setting like old
aspects yeah
where did they go where did it get there
we go okay son of rambo here we go
have you guys been enjoying this dream
so far let us know then i have no
choice but to shoot you and your cat do
you have any last
requests whoa
skills you're going to be the stunt man
in the film i'm making for screens
[Music]
william i'm not supposed to be friends
with you what was wrong with me
it's our religion if they find out our
friends then i'll be in the worst travel
ever
wow
ready three two one
whoa oh god
you're all right
isn't that the guy from where the
millers
look will polter vander snatch
[Music]
[Music]
well if i'm not needed i'll be taking my
camera back then don't be stupid
it's not you it's them i hate them well
this is sorry okay it was better when it
was just us two
oh two action
let's make the movie
[Applause]
hurry up people we're losing yeah
[Music]
[Music]
that was nice that was very i mean you
guys seen it
that's from 2000 that was so pleasant 12
years old oh that looks so pleasant that
looks really touching
that's an old [ __ ] movie and yeah and
i mean for for
film fans especially i have to imagine
anybody who's ever tried to make a
short when they were kids which we
certainly did oh man that looks like the
kind of movie that would make me cry
you know cry but like but like with that
swelling warm feeling we have seen the
greenland trailer
we yeah we watched it live on ben
bateman's show oh that's right we did
yeah we 100 we already did a reaction to
this man oh
poor gerard butler not making it onto
this appreciate it though
thank you niraj and we just watched it
guy richie's the gentleman trailer is
awesome
true that ethan holgate there is proof
of that
here on the street we just watched the
gentleman one earlier
sorry you guys can't hear it but the
youtube the youtube like you can go back
a page and it'll still just play the
sound
uh michael sorry we did watch it and
then michael swift
the last circus trailer oh the last
circus is that the
i think that's like an 80s movie right
all right let's find out let's check it
let's peep it all right we should just
what do you think should we do two more
and then
uh do the thing where we
do what campia does when he falls behind
when we do like a special
does a separate video and he's doing it
all in one take you know i think we got
to do that i guess yeah i guess that's
what we'll have today
gets away with it we can get away with
it that's how i run everything in my
life yeah man
oh this is last circus trailer this is a
red band trailer
should i find a green man trailer do we
want to risk no let's do it all right
risk it with the photo we've gone so far
well that's true
you know i'm always just looking out for
the last three minutes
who cares all right guys this is gonna
be a red
band trailer sir yeah and it's two
minutes and four seconds
so get ready so get ready look away if
you can't handle
things that are ready if you're a child
it's called the last circus
sent to us by mike uh michael swift
michael swift
we did the avengers game trailer guys
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
wow
jesus christ
this looks like a psychedelic american
beauty in a circus
interesting that was undoubtedly very
trippy
[Music]
what is happening ah
oh my goodness wow
wow wow
[Music]
god's name the last circus
this is 10 years old this is from
2010 this is from 2010
a young trapeze artist must decide
between her lust for sergio the happy
clown or her affection for javier this
sad clown
both of whom are deeply disturbed damn
that looks like what what what uh
country is this from
italy is this uh spain it's from spain
yeah it's spanish
wow i feel like uh alex yeah right
jared said it in the chat spanish rob
zombie that was like the
video that i was getting okay i've i've
heard of this guy before this guy uh uh
uh alex dillah
this is a really trippy trailer man i
remember when witching and bitching came
out in 2013 and i heard a good amount
about that but this looks absolutely
gonzo man
yeah spanish rob zombie is right all
right we got rainbow six tournament of
champions
super chat patrick but we did we did
already cover it patrick rasmussen i
hope you
that was i think out of all the movie
trailers we watched that one's the one
that's going to stand out to me the most
oh yeah that was so bizarre so [ __ ]
bizarre
oh i i do love a good taste of uh
something way out of the box though let
me handle the typing of this john so you
don't panic
oh just uh because there's a guy yeah
all right spanish ballad where do we go
that's a song yo
oh we can't do songs i'm sorry i'm sorry
josh is get uh
jf i appreciate your contribution but
we've made a couple of everywhere we
said we're doing this we couldn't we
can't do music because
uh we could have this stream be blocked
worldwide yeah
i mean this has a spotify link and all
that yeah
i'm sorry i don't want to rain on your
parade but i would also
yeah people in music especially be
claiming videos yeah like
we can get it we'll get a block
worldwide especially if we cover right
now
sorry jf we did make that note up front
but uh but thank you very much you're
still in the stream
if you're still in this trip three hours
later let me know and everybody else
thank you check it out
everybody else let's go go watch it go
watch the uh yeah
el cortez too bad [ __ ]
all right josiahgamer23 thank you buddy
yeah we watched the
we watched we watched a good amount of
it in the last first
live stream from earlier today part one
of this
and then uh let's see here have you guys
seen a trailer for summer of 84
or turbo kid oh neither but i've heard a
lot about
turbo kid um i don't know what summer of
84 is
i know a lot of people who loved turbo
kid when it dropped i feel like that
would be
kind of on brand for us but i uh don't
know summer of 84.
should we watch turbo kid or should we
watch
summer of 84 sound off in the comments
right the [ __ ] now yes
what do you think there's a bit of a
delay so we're going to be quiet here
all right oh [ __ ] pops in you guys are
killing it
how far behind are we we're okay so
that's
five but instead of one i said like an
hour ago we're not taking any more super
chats
let's see how far and then we got
another area this whole window over here
this is yeah where'd it go
where'd it go there we go
we got we don't have quite as many over
here no
this is a little more manageable the
last one was from 720.
yeah turbo kid we got one for 84. we got
a couple for turbo kit we got a few for
84. we got a few for 84.
okay what's it what's the what's the
vote here
uh is that slightly more
summer okay summer of turbo thank you
justin
it looks like summer of 84 is the one
all right summer of 84.
jared we did a jurassic park 1993
trailers revisited
already a long time ago not on a live
stream you could just type it in
okay summer of 84. that's what we're
going to watch right now
all right he linked that
hey luke is classy you are clever thing
is
in order for me to cover umbrella
academy there's a lot of other stuff i
gotta get done
so we're probably gonna have like
tonight so we're probably gonna
yeah we're gonna wrap up shortly and
then we're gonna just make up for this
in a
separate video going through all this
for you guys
yes yes all right here we go the
sheriff's office reports they're likely
looking for a white male
preferred targets appear to be males
aged 12 to 16.
it's a serial killer oh
gunpowder and sky they get us up once
the game chronicle received a letter
from an individual
calling themselves the cape may slayer
there's a serial killer on the loose
what else could possibly be this
exciting incoming titties
12 o'clock guys nikki kashuba
scientifically the perfect woman huh
better view of my room than i thought
sweet dreams emergency meetings
treehouse
now mackie is the cape may slayer
mackie's a cop with a sick reputation
isn't counting on us
this is disturbia in the 80s
that's blood baby guys i'm freaking out
okay
relax after 30. it's gonna be fine now
go
you're gonna get caught either by mackie
or your dad i know
i'm right about him that doesn't prove
anything are you with me
this looks like it could be better than
easter you're trying to save people yeah
you're not you guys in the station are
gonna love this just let it go
sorry again if you're uh grounded let's
see if i can get you out of this house
no hard feelings
looks like a chubby or bow burner
[Applause]
even serial killers live next door to
somebody
yeah that looks great yeah it looks like
fun oh [ __ ] someone said they heard okay
who said that bradley in the chat
hey what's up bradley he's saying he
heard about this from red letter media
oh no that's sweet
all right must be good if they like it
must be
good it's the way i mean it's the
easiest way to gauge anything
yeah well thank you so much mark leach
definitely gonna have to check out turbo
kit at some point though all right
let's see here let's end this
on a solid i would okay
uh all right we could do tron legacy for
the other one
daisy confused let's end this stream on
a solid one here
uh okay react to meet the spy
what i want one that's like crazy
anise is not in the chat right now so so
it would be better for the other one
uh peaky blinders is pretty popular
we're deciding really quick guys hold on
thank you so much ramiro sanchez for
showing support
even if you don't have a request
oh hello to ulysses kansas how do we end
this on the rick and morty season five
why not trailer why not type it in john
rick and morty season five i've i'm only
on rick and morty season two
how far in i'm on episode five
all right not bad i guess this is it
first look rick and morty season five
i'm gonna probably forget how this goes
but everyone loves rick and morty
it doesn't seem as though i i actually
revisited a little bit for the first
time la
in a while last night yeah first look
here we go hey gene jeter gene
welcome just in time just the time we're
watching
we're almost there leave me morty it's
the only way
what were we are we blades in that one
that's tight just stay with me
i'm scared morty i can see the end oh
god there's nothing
i know i always said that but oh god
there's really nothing i'm sorry morty
i'm a silly man i'm a silly small man i
wasted it all
i'm i'm sorry i got you into this but
how about i get us
out of this
this must be done out of boards or
something
hello hey jessica it's morty from school
oh hey morty
what's up um i just want to say that
you're really great i know the timing
never really worked out with us but
you're really great and i wish i got to
know you better oh
i mean that's a lot oh uh yeah sorry i
guess i just no i just
wish you said it sooner what yeah
oh no
[Laughter]
no no no no
yeah that's a great point tonight do you
like to watch a movie or something um
yeah great sounds great
great see you later morty
[ __ ] i want to live [ __ ] death i want to
live
you got this morning
[Applause]
where where are we home right where we
belong
no seriously morty where the [ __ ] are we
i don't i don't know the ocean the ocean
ocean on earth yeah i guess so [ __ ] holy
[ __ ] we have to go we have to go right
now you touched the ocean morty
oh [ __ ] no oh god
richard you have desecrated this secret
treaty betwixt
land and sea now face the wrath of your
once and eternal foe
mr nimbus sorry who the [ __ ] is that
my nemesis what my nemesis okay
hey but what was his name again i am
missing so many enemies
[Music]
yes siri bob that show is one of the
most inventive [ __ ] things i've ever
seen
it hands down it's like so hilarious
wildly inventive too
love the aquaman angle that we got here
in this rick and morty trailer
does this guy have yeah jesus christ oh
buddy
all right guys okay
forgive this was an experiment we will
have to make up
for the ones that we weren't able to we
do have to we do have to call it a night
we want to do let's do a speed round of
just the ones that aren't requests
really quick let's just
say the ones that aren't requests yeah
yeah anything that's just people saying
hey
okay um so we got let's see ramiro
sanchez do you
just want to show support no request
thank you ramiro
thank you so much nice to see you back
in our live stream shout out to the
discord family from anissa
[ __ ] yeah um
[Music]
i love you guys random andy's channel
what's up miss you too random andy
thank you so much for popping in um
let's see
bernice panders i just got in but have
you guys ever played or watched
playthrough of the last of us if not
please check out yt gameplay movies
have not actually hmm i've never seen a
a stream of any of the last of us one or
two actually well stay tuned
yeah because you can watch me uh patrick
hogue what's up dawg
we should definitely do a serbian film
commentary
i have a copy i have an unopened
governor
patrick of the uncut version great to
see you here thank you buddy for saying
hey
um let's do this uh i don't know if we
could infinite
react to my hero academia full smash uh
animatic just because of the anime it's
really hard to get those up on youtube
uh but thank you for the love
oh big big roy tent there we go
big boy trent big boy trent i played the
first two hours of hellblade it really
isn't soft and delightful
that has a lot to say about mental
illness it also has a sequel coming out
either this or next year
notice me big boy trent appreciate all
the information on that buddy that was a
really cool trailer i would love to see
it
i love your name by the way big boy
trent and uh thank you
sylvester fryzon jr thank you sylvester
fryson
and really quick let's just make sure
that we don't have any on the thank you
to
young stanley tv don't know what you
said actually but
thanks for that anyway and uh yeah
uh and sylvester it's all right i don't
think the stream did the song did affect
the stream i think the
stream labs just got a little overloaded
there um but really great job on your
video again
great job again sylvester um will we do
more
gameplay vids i'm sure i'm sure
thank you for asking uh brendan v oh
you just you just submitted one thank
you buddy hey
uh yeah i love you too bye too brendan i
hope you're feeling better as of late
man yeah i hope you're doing all right
sending you love um i think that's all
the salutations for today
so we gotta screenshot these yeah and
then either tomorrow or on
sunday we will just do a giant
gun cut gauntlet uncut reactions cut
just like a medley all of them a
conveyor belt
promise we'll get to them like and
honestly
i can tell that most people here who had
requests at 5 p.m
have already left the stream so it
stands to reason
we will make it up and we will just do a
catch-up
just a solid video of all those reaction
requests
yeah and uh they'll go up either i'm
just i'm gonna
say sunday
i think we can sunday is probably the
best day to do it right yeah
because it will be uncut it'll be out
it'll be pretty simple looking but it'll
be
it'll be there thank you guys to
everyone who's been here the entire time
um i really appreciate the support thank
you everyone who was on the last stream
and then came over here after that crash
yeah thanks for sticking with us
and uh thanks for all your submissions
for all your feedback for all your love
everything much love to everyone
i'm so hungry take care guys take care
i'm glad this went well i'm glad
somebody thinks this is
this is a real experiment we knew we'd
fall behind
uh but thanks for bearing with us i feel
a little bad about it but we'll promise
to just make it up to you guys thank you
guys so much for being here this was fun
be well peeps